et sans détour ça tombe bien c'est
benoît hamon qui répond à nos questions
bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous alors
à l'heure qu'il est vous êtes ex
secrétaire national à l'europe pour le
parti socialiste vous avez démissionné
tout à l'heure pourquoi est ce que c'est
parce que vous étiez au style oh oui ou
faute de consensus d'unanimité général
témoin j'ai été nommé secrétaire
national à l'europe au moment où on
sortir d'un traumatisme qui était celui
de traité constitutionnel européen
l'opposition entre socialistes
l'objectif était dépassée ce clivage
entre partisans du oui les partisans du
non est trouvé au moment de la
présidentielle qu au moment de
l'adoption de ce traité ou pas une
position commune à tous les socialistes
je pense qu'elle était possible elle a
été évoquée par tout le monde au parti
socialiste elle pouvait être
l'abstention est en même temps le rappel
de notre attachement au fait que le
peuple reste le souverain et qu'il
fallait passer par référendum ainsi ce
qui a cloché qu'est ce qui a cloché le
fait que à la fois nous prenons nos
distances par rapport aux ce mode de
ratification qui était le noter que nous
avons défendues pendant l'élection
présidentielle ségolène royal parlé d'
obligations démocratiques à passer par
référendum et puis parce que aujourd'hui
les réflexes sont revenus en faveur du
oui en faveur du non et moi j'ai le
sentiment que cette division n'est pas
saine et je ne me voyais pas être
l'interprète de cette polyphonie j'en ai
tiré des conséquences qui sont de ne
plus être secrétaire national à l'europe
tout simplement c'est pas un drame alors
justement pour nos téléspectateurs
comment il faut interpréter le oui
aujourd'hui de ce qu'ils avaient dit non
au référendum sur la constitution n'est
pas fou leur demande et j'observe que
moi je l'interprète comme le chemin
d'hommes et de femmes qui analyse le
texte et le contexte c'est sûr que ce
n'est pas exactement le même texte est
pas exactement le même contexte il nous
aurons des difficultés à envisager de
nouvelles fenêtres de tir en termes de
renégociation cela étant dit ce qui est
d'abord important c'est de dire qu'est
ce que nous sommes attachés ou pas au
référendum le peuple a défait une chose
l'ancien traité constitutionnel européen
il le seul légitime à refaire ce qu'il a
défait et là où nicolas sarkozy a peur
d'aller devant le peuple le parti
socialiste qui a défendu cette position
qui elle soutenu par près de deux tiers
des français dans tous les sondages
d'opinion le parti socialiste doit
rester attachés à cette ligne là et à
défendre le référendum ce soir nous
avons pris nos distances vous le dis par
rapport à cette position et nous avons
choisi sur le contenu du texte c'est
bien un peu de rejouer le match comme il
ya deux ans comme si ça ne nous avait
pas suffisamment kouteiba mois vis-à-vis
de cela je préférais simplement prendre
mes distances il ya quelques semaines
sur ce même plateau vous étiez par
parole du parti socialiste et je vous
demandais de quel parti socialiste vous
étiez le porte parole et vous m'aviez
répondu
de celui de françois hollande donc de la
ligne de françois hollande ce soir
françois hollande et a dit qu'il est
satisfait de ce oui que les problèmes
sont derrière vous ce qui veut dire
qu'aujourd'hui vous n'êtes plus sur la
ligne de françois hollande non mais je
reste membre du parti dirigé par
françois hollande je respecte mon parti
je me pliais ses décisions je le
servirait d'une autre manière mais là où
je suis en désaccord avec ses choix et
là on me demande d'être l'interprète sur
les questions européennes de choix avec
laquelle je suis en désaccord tout
simplement je dis je ne peux pas le
faire parce que c'est un désaccord avec
mes convictions et le mandat qu'on
m'avait donnée qui était d'essayer de
trouver une solution commune je déplore
commission ayant pas parvenu si on
prends ma part j'ai sans doute échoué
moi même mais voilà il faut faire tirer
des conséquences simple c'est joli pas
un drame mais je regrette que le ps soit
sur cette ligne là aujourd'hui et qu'ils
ne servent pas la compréhension d'une
question aussi importante que celle de
l'avenir de l'europe merci beaucoup
benoît hamon d'avoir répondu à nos
questions merci